bonsoir à tous je suis ravi d'être ici
pour vous voir ce soir
alors ce que vous voyez juste derrière
c'est ce qui a été l' équilibre pour moi
pendant toute mon enfance et une bonne
partie de mon adolescence et en gymnaste
j'ai été j'ai été confronté à des
notions de perfectionnisme de discipline
également j'ai grandi là dedans faut
savoir que la gymnastique c'est une
véritable école de la vie on vous
apprend à être parfaite dans toutes les
situations
les compétitions je les ai accumulé avec
mon équipe alors comme ton j'ai rêvé de
faire les jeux olympiques
malheureusement ça n'a pas été le cas
jetez pas la meilleure mais j'étais très
loin d'être la dernière est également
et pendant ces événements vous devez
parfaite aussi bien dans votre
présentation donc sur votre nuque sur
votre coiffure et mais également sur vos
enchaînements bien évidemment le moindre
déséquilibre un agrès où on se rate une
figure qui est loupée et c'est les
points c'est les points qui s'envolent
et le classement et votre classement qui
descend et en fait avec cette discipline
les gens avaient une image de moi est
une fille forte qu'ils avaient confiance
en elle sauf que la réalité était pas du
tout c'était pas du tout ça j'ai
toujours grandi avec cette idée que tout
ce que je faisais n'était jamais assez
bien qu en tant qu'individu je n'étais
pas assez bien et que je n'avait en
aucun cas le droit d'accepter le moindre
compliment qu'on pouvait me faire et
accepter la moindre victoire
c'était c'était pas possible j'ai grandi
comme ça j'ai accepté j'ai évolué ainsi
malheureusement ou heureusement certains
diront j'ai pris des coups dans la vie
des coups assez important et par ce
souci de perfectionnisme et de contrôle
chez les a encaissées malgré tout j'ai
fait comme si tout allait bien quand ils
sont arrivés et du coup sûr cette poudre
que je peux représenter finalement comme
comme ma vie
sur rester en équilibre sauf qu'à un
moment je n'y paraît déséquilibré par
ses coûts et un moment où j'ai chuté
lourdement très lourdement d'ailleurs
puisque j'ai failli ne pas être avec
vous ce soir
excusez moi un raid émotion alors monde
et d' équilibre il est très particulier
c'est ce que l'on nomme l'anorexie une
maladie taboue insidieuse qui m'a suivi
pendant plus de quatre ans de ma vie
alors je tiens à vous préciser que je me
suis pas réveillé un matin en me disant
tiens ça y est je mords et ou de manger
je vais faire comme le mannequin
tu vas me faire perdre du poids ça va
être super ça absolument pas été du tout
ça comme je voulais expliquer j'ai pris
des gros coup dans masi harcèlement a vu
des choses qui me sont totalement
personnelle et cumulé à ce besoin de
contrôle externe extrême par nom qui
faisait partie de moi j'ai fini par j'ai
fini par jeter ça constitue en moi une
bombe à retardement qui n'attendait que
d'exploser et cette bombe elle a explosé
lors du décès de ma grand mère
maternelle alors elle est décédée à
quatre ans désormais et il faut savoir
qu'à ce moment là j'ai passé mes
concours justement pour rentrer à
l'istec et d'autres examens qui était
très important pour moi et pour une
personne qui est très perfectionnisme et
qui adore le contrôle qui vit que pour
ça son décès ça a été et roches ima je
n'avais jamais été confronté à la mort
encore moins à celle d'une personne
aussi proche de moi et par souci de
perfection j'ai occulté sa mort juste le
temps de passer ses examens
j'ai fait comme s'il n'était jamais rien
arrivé je voulais être sûr de réussir ça
peut paraître égoïste mais ça a été ma
manière de de gérer c'est à ce moment là
j'étais pas capable de gérer le deuil
donc je me suis
je me suis accroché à ses examens je les
ai réussi ses examens ya pas eu de
soucis sauf que le revers de la médaille
il est arrivé quelques mois plus tard de
manière très importante il faut savoir
que pendant tout ce temps je
m'inquiétais absolument pas de ma peine
mais surtout de celle de ma mère ma mère
et à se faire également de l'anorexie
jusqu'à ses 30 ans en très très
longtemps
il ma plus grande crainte cité de la
voir s'arrêter de manger la voir
rechuter
j'avais perdu ma grand mère il n'était
pas possible dans ma tête de perdre ma
maman et au lieu de m'inquiéter pour moi
je me suis inquiété pour elle je
vérifiais tous ses repas je l'appelais
constamment je voulais vérifier que tout
allait bien et en fait ma mère elle a
très bien géré et elle allait très bien
il ya eu aucun souci mais moi il fallait
que je sois sûr qu'elle aille bien et
donc en fait c'est pas elle qui s'arrête
à manger c'est moi alors ce qui a été au
départ un grand manque d'appétit fini
par se finit par devenir un véritable
contrôle extrême de l'alimentation et de
mon corps j'ai commencé par retirer
certains aliments mon assiette
jusqu'à ce qu'il ne reste que plus
qu'une pomme par jour et quelques
galettes de riz pour vous dire t'es pas
grand chose ce qui s'est passé c'est que
j'ai perdu j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de poids en très peu de temps
j'ai atteint les le seuil des 40 kg je
les ai même descendu un petit peu en
dessous
il faut savoir que c'est un poids qui
était pas du tout adapté à ma
morphologie
je tenais plus debout j'étais plus
capable de suivre une conversation avec
quelqu'un ça me demandait beaucoup trop
d'énergie ce moment là
et à un moment où il a fallu que je sois
hospitalisé parce qu'il fallait que je
reste en vie tout simplement
il est arrivé en décembre 2014 donc
juste avant les fêtes de noël quelques
semaines avant voilà le couperet est
tombé j'ai tu arrivée à l'hôpital à ce
moment là il est médecin ils ont été
clairs s'ils ne reprenaient pas
rapidement du poids et que je n'en aurai
pas à manger c'était la réanimation qui
m'attendait et les fêtes de noël je
pouvais les oubliés avec mes parents
alors forcément ça change un peu
on finit par réfléchir et j'ai pas je
n'arrivais pas je pouvais par manger
c'était pas possible donc les médecins
ils ont pris la décision radicale de
sonder ce que vous voyez juste derrière
pour me faire reprendre du poids très
rapidement pas que je tombe encore plus
et je suis sorti bonne nouvelle j'ai
sorti en 24 décembre pied pour pour les
fêtes
j'étais pas trop en état mais c'était la
délivrance pour toute ma famille et
s'est passé quelque chose d'étrange à ce
moment là c'est que quand j'ai passé les
portes de l'hôpital
ça faisait plusieurs semaines que
j'avais pas mis les pieds par terre que
je pouvais pas marcher tout en fauteuil
roulant et j'avais l'impression de
renaître à ce moment là c'était une
nouvelle vie l'impression de venir sur
terre pour une nouvelle fois en fait et
c'était c'était peu de le dire puisque
après la fallu reconstruire toute ma vie
et c'est ce qui a été très compliqué je
suis remonté sur cette poutre finalement
en me disant que tout allait bien se
passer que j'étais sur la bonne voie
parce que j'avais décidé d'aller bien
sûr que ça c'est pas du tout passé comme
ça alors absolument pas imaginez vous
vous réveillez de ce qu'on peut
apparenter d'un très grand sommeil et
toute votre vie est parti en lambeaux
votre fiancée est parti vos amis
également et vous ne vous reconnaissez
même plus dans le miroir pour me dire
c'est pas facile et quand on voit tous
ces débris de la vie de votre vie qui
sont par terre eh ben on prend peur
donc moi j'ai pris peur j'ai reculé
tellement de fois sur cette poutre si
vous saviez donc j'ai rechuté oui j'en
ai pas honte j'ai rechuté à nombreuses
reprises j'ai refait des
hospitalisations
[Musique]
et puis à un moment où juste après ma
dernière hospitalisation il ya peu j'ai
fini par dire stop par me dire stop à
moi même j'ai fini par dire c'est plus
possible il faut que ça s'arrête
et cette force que j'avais pas en moins
pour y arriver je suis allé la chercher
là où elle était c'est à dire dans mes
proches j'ai enfin accepté l'aide que je
refusais jusqu alors alors cette fois je
suis allé là puiser dans le sourire de
mes parents quand jérôme anger avec eux
je suis allé là puiser dans le rire de
ma nièce sixtine qui a rigolé en me
demandant masai et ati est ce que tu
peux manger des pâtes avec moi je suis
allée la prendre dans la fierté de mes
amis non une amie qui est là ce soir qui
me vont encore évoluer chaque mois est
en fait s'il n'avait pas été là si je
n'étais pas allé chercher cette force en
eux je ne serais pas là aujourd'hui
devant vous ils ont été nécessaires pour
que j'aille mieux pour que je m'en sorte
c'était sais je les remercie d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils m'ont soutenu
indéfiniment ayant besoin d'un soutien
sans faille et à un moment où nombreuses
fois j'ai voulu tout arrêter
g j'en pouvais plus parce que c'est
tellement dur vous rendez pas compte je
crois qu'en fait retrouver les
reconstruire sa vie après un événement
pareil après a remporté avec la mort
c'est finalement encore plus dur que de
la maladie oui je peux le dire
et du coup il ya un jour il ya peu il ya
une personne de mon entourage qui m'a
dit au détour d'une conversation mais de
toute façon toi géraldine n'a absolument
pas d orge les malpris fait pas plaisir
mais en fait cette personne je les
remercie aujourd'hui parce qu'elle avait
totalement raison
j'allais mue en surface mais au fond
c'était absolument pas le cas
je faisais juste illusions et ce
discours en fait m'a permis de réaliser
que ma qu'il fallait que j'y aille enfin
et que j'y crois donc aujourd'hui
je vais beaucoup mieux ça serait
d'ailleurs est ce que j'ai envie de vous
dire c'est qu'on peut y arriver est
arrivé
je ne sais pas quel est votre souci et
j'espère d'ailleurs pour vous vous n'en
avez pas mais si tel est le cas juste
que vous compreniez que que c'est
possible que dans la vie tout peut
arriver
je crois que j'en suis l'exemple même
aujourd'hui que que c'est possible et
pour vous le prouver que c'est possible
je vais faire quelque chose ce soir ça
vous paraît ça vous paraît totalement
anodin mais pour moi c'est très lourd de
sens j'ai demandé à marine de m'apporter
quelque chose
voilà j'ai décidé je déguster un petit
bout c'était clair que je suis allée
acheter tout à l'heure devant vous pour
vous prouver que c'est possible je m'en
suis sorti donc si jamais vous avez un
seau si vous pouvez vous en sortir alors
nous prévient je crois que j'ai vu qu'il
ya plein de très bonnes choses qui vous
attendent juste après donc moi je vais
manger un petit bout de ça mais on
pourra aller grignoter ensemble juste un
vrai y'a pas de soucis vous inquiétez
pas allez on y va
[Applaudissements]